we were on afghan territory fighting the
counterterrorism fight alongside afghans
alongside allies from nato
using intelligence assets that we had
developed to find bin laden and kill him
in pakistan
that 20 years bought us
a piece that i did not think possible
on september 12th
[Music]
this week is the 20th anniversary of the
september 11th attacks
20 years ago 19 al-qaeda terrorists
hijacked four airliners three of which
hit their targets
tower 1 and tower 2 of the world trade
center as well as the pentagon
those attacks resulted in 2997 deaths
and 25 000 injuries altering forever the
fabric of american life
the following day in an address to the
nation president george w bush declared
war on the terrorists who committed
these acts
this is an enemy that tries to
hide but it won't be able to hide
forever
this is an enemy that thinks his harbors
are safe
but they won't be safe forever
closely involved with the decisions and
operations to come was national security
adviser condoleezza rice who joins us
today to discuss the anniversary and the
latest developments we've witnessed the
past few weeks in afghanistan
condoleezza rice went on to become the
secretary of state during president
bush's second term and before this
administration secretary rice also
served on the national security council
for president h.w bush now she's
director of the hoover institution at
stanford university
in response to that dark moment in
september 2001 secretary rice led the
charge of transformational diplomacy
efforts by the united states to develop
democratic systems of government
throughout the middle east
with the incredibly fast fall of the
democratic afghan government that the
united states co-developed will get her
reaction and thoughts on how the current
administration could and should have
handled the situation
plus what secretary rice makes of the
idea that afghanistan was a so-called
endless war
and what we have forgotten in america in
these 20 years since that tragic day
[Music]
and welcome this is the ben shapiro show
sunday special this show is sponsored by
expressvpn don't like big tech and the
government spying on you visit
expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to conor lisa rice
in just one moment but first a lot of
people don't really think about their
online data until it's just too late
well every time you connect to an
unencrypted network in cafes hotels
airports etc your online data is not
secured any hacker on the same network
can gain access to and steal your
personal data passwords financial
details your emails it doesn't take much
technical knowledge to hack somebody
just some cheap hardware is needed a
smart 12 year old could do it your data
is valuable hackers can make up to a
thousand dollars per person selling
personal information on the dark web you
need a secure vpn to protect yourself
and i can say with full confidence
express vpn is the best on the market
here's why expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet hackers can't steal your
sensitive data expressvpn's technology
is so secure it would take a hacker with
a super computer over a billion years to
get past expressvpn's encryption another
reason i love expressvpn is how easy it
is to use unlike other vpns you don't
have to input or program anything you
just fire up the app you click one
button to connect it works on all
devices including phones laptops tablets
and more so you can stay secure on the
go secure your online data today by
visiting
expressvpn.com that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
you can get an extra three months for
free expressvpn.com
ben trust the people i trust with my own
online security expressvpn.com slash pen
con lisa rice an honor to have you here
thanks much for joining the show
a pleasure to be with you so let's start
with obviously what's what's in the news
uh first your reaction to the
precipitous and catastrophic withdrawal
i think my feeling's pretty clear on
this from afghanistan which seemed to be
not only poorly planned tactically but
has some pretty dramatic geostrategic
consequences
well i i wrote about this uh then
because i i think the real issue here is
that uh even if one believed that it was
time to withdraw which i actually don't
believe it was time to withdraw but if
one believed that it was time to
withdraw
this could have been done in a more
orderly fashion for instance we know
that the taliban don't fight in the
winter there is a fighting season in
afghanistan
it would have been perfectly logical to
wait until they had gone back into the
mountains of pakistan i think it would
have been wise to hang on to
bagram maybe even some of our other
seven airfields that we had there
so that transport of people out could
have been slower more orderly
could have taken place from more secure
locations i've been to hamad karzai
international airport it's not a place
that you would want to try and secure
it's very very close to the city
bagram is uh
tens of miles away and so i think that
there were ways to do this
uh in a fashion that we wouldn't have
seen the precipitous fall of of kabul
and where we wouldn't have had the kind
of chaos that we had at the airport we
can perhaps get into later why i think
it might have been better to stay in
general but just talking about the
extraction itself now i do want to say
the men and women of the american armed
forces as always did heroic work to get
as many people out as they did under
extraordinarily difficult circumstances
chaotic circumstances where there was no
way for force protection
we lost 13 brave people
but uh i just want to say the american
military again
covers itself in uh considerable um
excellence and glory as the secretary
rice let's talk about the enormous
amount of revisionist history that's now
being put out there as a justification
for this pull-out and that there is some
bipartisan stuff happening there with
people on both right and left talking
about how afghanistan was a
nation-building exercise a failed
nation-building exercise this is why we
had to pull out or that we were in the
middle of an america's endless war our
longest war and therefore we had to pull
out so why don't we start from the
beginning you obviously were at the
white house for september 11th can you
give us the the sort of timeline here
what was the original justification just
to remind folks who may not remember
since it's now been two decades what was
the reason we went into afghanistan in
the first place what were the goals we
were trying to achieve
we went into afghanistan
because that had been the source
of the planning plotting and indeed the
ability to attack
on september 11th
that's why we went to afghanistan it was
a security concern and i can remember
the president's
concern that another attack a follow-on
attack might be imminent and
we waited some three weeks before we
actually went into afghanistan because
we had a lot of work to do and i'll come
back to one of those elements which
we've now given up but we had a lot of
work to do to try to get
forces in a position
to take down the taliban which was
harboring al-qaeda
that was the reason for going to
afghanistan what people don't understand
about so-called nation-building
is that if you are going to prevent a
place from returning to terrorism once
you've killed the first wave of
terrorists it has to be something of a
stable government you have to try and
create
circumstances under which you can work
with partners as we have been doing for
20 years
for counter-terrorism operations
where you can work with partners as we
have been doing for 20 years with our
nato allies
to try and stabilize the situation so
that there isn't a swamp for the
terrorists to to be active in you have
to work with our allies as we have been
uh to continue to have intelligence
assets on the ground and so
uh an afghanistan in which we were
present
i think was good for the afghan people
it did do good things for women it did
do good things for
the afghan people having suffered under
the horrors of the taliban but ben that
wasn't the reason to use the american
armed forces the reason to use the
american armed forces was to secure a
place where we could fight the war on
terror where we could have
counterterrorism operations where we
could have intelligence operations where
we could have an air base from which to
fly
drones and close air support this was a
strategic asset in afghanistan it was
not largesse and uh and simply uh
humanitarianism so secretary rights
there are a lot of early successes in
the war obviously the toppling of the
taliban inside of three weeks and the
establishment of a provisional
government and there were early
successes even in experiments with
democracy in afghanistan by 2005 2006
2007 there was a significant insurgence
maybe you can take us through sort of
the history of the development of the
war because i think a lot of americans
are trapped in a mindset about what
afghanistan was that is circa 2009 2010
and had nothing to do with where we were
circa 2021. we were uh after the
overthrow of the taliban um
let me just say one other thing but
nobody was in any way
overly optimistic about afghanistan we
knew how hard it was going to be i
remember
on that saturday morning at
camp david after
9 11
looking at this rolled out map of
afghanistan and thinking oh no not
afghanistan this is a place that great
powers go to go to die the british the
soviet union we knew that this was a
tough place the first day that i flew
into afghanistan some several months
later i remember thinking these people
have high mountains and dirt this is
going to be a very difficult operation
but we were
succeeding and by the way talking about
allies and friends we had mobilized nato
under article 5 to help us the germans
the french the italians the the
canadians were all out in the field the
dutch uh trying to help build this uh
afghan army and this afghan government
they were having elections women were
going to school girls were going to
school women were going into the
professions and so
we had many successful successes in
afghanistan but the most important thing
is that we were really making progress
in terms of creating a stable foundation
for counter-terrorism operations for
intelligence from which to carry out
those operations and i mentioned ben
that it took us a while
in to to start the war in afghanistan we
couldn't find a place for our air assets
to operate close air support to the
afghan
fighters for instance and so i remember
paying a king's ransom to
karimov the then dictator of uzbekistan
to let us use his airfields
that's why it's so sad that we gave up
this strategic asset in bagram because
now we're back in a situation where our
closest airfields are in the middle east
in qatar uh that is a that's an own goal
that's a a mistake but we were making a
lot of progress i will tell you that one
of the things we were never able to
really
get a handle on
was pakistan
pakistani territory
continued to be a haven
for the haqqani network and other
terrorists to go back and forth across
that border
in the south of afghanistan and i think
that one of the big failures
one of the reasons that it was hard to
to to defeat the taliban was that they
did have a safe haven in pakistan so
secretary rice there's been a major
mission shift under president obama uh
early on in his administration he made
clear that he thought iraq was the bad
war and the useless war and afghanistan
was the good war and so he did a couple
of troop surges including a sort of
half-hearted large troop surge i say
half-hearted because he had been
requested many more troops by general
petraeus than he actually gave him and
then immediately upon putting the troops
in he said that we were going to start
withdrawing we were going to change the
mission from essentially holding as much
territory as possible under the national
government to retrenching within certain
more populated areas and you know using
that territory is basically a base of
operations we're also going to draw down
american troop levels from the 20 30 40
000 range all the way down to 10 000 and
below what did you make of that move and
and what did that mean for how
sustainable situation was on the ground
in afghanistan well i was initially
hardened by the idea of a troop search
although the conditions in iraq and the
conditions in afghanistan were very
different
we had had a successful troop surge in
iraq that essentially won that war um
we then of course gave up territory isis
came back but i think you could say that
in 2008 2009 uh iraq was was pretty
stable so i was i was a fan of of troop
searches and i thought well this is a
good idea but then i started reading
that we weren't going to do enough to
really make a difference if you're going
to do a troop search
do a troop search don't put limitations
on the numbers of troops that you're
going to use
the other thing is i've never understood
this idea that you telegraph
to your enemy we're only staying for
this long and then we're going to start
to withdraw and we're retreating to this
this place it's as if during world war
ii uh we started broadcasting uh to the
germans or the japanese exactly what we
planned to do with the battle plan
and that tendency to want to talk about
uh uh where we're moving to and how
we're going to retrench and when we're
going to withdraw i think has been uh
really one of the most pernicious
uh elements of our uh military policy
over the last several years so secretary
bryce in a second i want to ask you
about some of the arguments that have
been made in favor of the withdrawal
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so when i'm traveling i just
don't sleep the way i do at home there
are a lot of reasons for that one of the
big reasons i don't have the mattress
made just for me i've got a helix sleep
mattress helix sleep has a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete it matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you whether
you're a side sleeper or a hot sleeper
whether you like a plush or a firm bed
with helix there's no more confusion and
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by both gq
and wired magazine cnn called it the
most comfortable mattress they've ever
slept on they've got a 10-year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but i promise
you will go to helixsleep.com ben take
their two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life if you're compromising on your
mattress that is really a mistake
considering how often you're on it like
every night and how much time you spend
on it and how much you need your sleep
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders today for our
listeners get up to 200 bucks off at
helix sleep.com ben my wife and i love
our helix sleep mattress we get on that
thing every night it is made for us and
we sleep like babies you can too
helixsleep.com
okay so let's talk about the various
arguments that are made in favor of
withdrawal some of which i think are
just disconnected from reality secretary
right so the one that you hear the most
is that this was an endless war you
heard president biden say that
repeatedly over the course of the last
several months by the time we left we
had a troop level that was basically
ranking number nine in terms of
countries where we actually had troops
we had under 3 000 troops in afghanistan
we had had zero combat casualties since
february of 2020 and yet there seems to
be this great urgent drive to remove all
the troops as soon as possible under the
rubric of endly endless war
what did you make of that particular
argument
well when the american president keeps
telling the american people that this is
an endless war that we have to get out
of
even if they're not paying a lot of
attention because afghanistan had gone
quieter as you noted
they're going to start to think it's an
endless war and we have to get out of it
and here i will say i i don't think we
had the best policies i and i've said
this before under the trump
administration either this notion that
america couldn't sustain a few thousand
troops
in a strategically vital part of the
world
where we were still fighting terrorist
and terrorist resurgence
where we had an air base that could help
us keep an eye on both pakistan not that
stable a place with nuclear weapons and
iran one are probably our most uh our
pitched enemy in the middle east the
idea that we couldn't sustain that as a
great power as a superpower was really
extraordinary and here's the argument i
would have hoped we would have said uh
we are
a country that benefited for a couple of
centuries by our great oceans protecting
us and peaceful neighbors to the north
and the south we found out on september
11th that we weren't protected we
decided we were going to take the war to
them so we didn't have to fight it on
our soil
that means that we need to forward
deploy our forces to fight them out
there so we don't have to fight them in
here
that means that we may have to deploy
small numbers contingents of american
forces intelligence assets and military
hardware forward in places like
afghanistan where we can with allies
from around the world as well as with
afghan allies continue to prosecute the
war on terror so we don't have to
prosecute it at home i wish somebody had
made that argument maybe we should take
responsibility ben those of us in the
bush administration for not making that
argument were forcefully enough
we were pleased with the good we were
doing for the afghan people but they did
a lot of good for us too in letting us
use their territory
for our own protection
i would also have said
we've done this forward deployment
before
our longest war is actually korea
it is an armistice not a victory in war
we have 28 000 american forces on the
korean peninsula
because even a powerful
korean south korean army can't stand
alone against the north
and so
why do we think that a
younger weaker afghan army can stand
alone against an insurgency but i would
have made the strategic argument i wish
we'd made it better now secretary rice
let's talk about the afghan army for a
second because this is another excuse
that's been used lately is the
incredibly quick collapse of the afghan
army uh president biden himself has
blamed the afghan army he suggested that
they didn't have any will to fight but
basically if they weren't capable of
holding up their their own country at
this point there was nothing that five
or ten years would have done down the
road he's literally said that uh it
seems to me that that is again utterly
disconnected from the facts on the
ground namely the fact that we built the
afghan army so they could explicitly
work with us in specific ways and then
we removed all of their support bases
and told everyone in afghanistan we were
leaving well i've heard many people now
say maybe we built the afghan army too
much in our own image we built them
needing air power for instance and
needing
the support of our air power and then of
course we took away
the contractors that were maintaining
the aircraft
american pilots were no longer
uh flying uh and and training them and
helping them uh to fly these air
missions uh you make a good point about
uh telling them that we were leaving uh
i imagine the scene uh you know that uh
the taliban which was making inroads we
have to be clear about that the taliban
goes into some area
encounters afghan military personnel
says you do know that the americans are
leaving you're going to be left here
with us
if you resist we're going to kill your
children so how about you come over to
our side and lay down your weapons
it's not hard to see why the morale of
the afghan army collapsed under those
circumstances when we didn't even tell
the new commander of bagram air force
base to whom we were turning it over
in the afghan commander that we were
leaving we left in the middle of the
night we did we did nothing really to
shore up their sense of their ability to
fight and if one thing really
really rankles me this idea that
they they didn't fight they chose to to
to surrender to the taliban
they lost 66 000 people in this war
i was talking with
some of my colleagues former military
officers they talk about
a general who we now think
an afghan general who we now think is
trapped behind taliban lines who lost
both his legs in a fight a firefight
that we were involved in
and he can't get out he couldn't get to
the airport
i thought that
if one thing really bothered me it was
the
the heartlessness
of talking about afghan fighters in that
way when they'd given so much
yes people surrendered they surrendered
rather quickly
but i don't think we gave him a chance
secretary rice one of the other things
that's been said is that the afghan
government was corrupt that there were
serious corruption issues going back all
the way to the karzai administration in
afghanistan uh that the united states
was never able to sort of wrap our arms
around that and thus you know there was
not any support for the interim
government or for the the current
national government of afghanistan any
real measure that tribalism was
eventually going to replace that anyway
it seems to me that there's a bit of
historical ignorance when it comes to
comparative situations in the the south
korean government didn't hold an
election until the 80s were literally
there for 30 to 40 years before they
held the free and fair election uh so
you know giving people a couple of
decades to move from
you know absolute tyranny uh and
tribalism towards something remotely
resembling a democracy actually takes a
fair bit of time but what do you make of
of the development of afghanistan's
government well i'm glad you mentioned
the south korean uh government ben they
were actually a military dictatorship
for a while
yes look the afghan government and and i
fought this every day as national
security adviser and then the secretary
we were never able to get a hand on
their corruption and we were never able
to get a hand on a handle on the drug
trade there's no doubt about that at
full stop
and it did
undermine and erode confidence of the
afghan population in their government
there there's also no doubt about that
but they aren't alone in
being a government that was uh that had
a problem with corruption
and i thought that this last government
uh was trying to to deal with some of
those problems it takes time sometimes
to root out corruption but whatever you
think about the afghan government and
their problems with corruption their
problems with the with the drug trade
their problems with tribalism uh they
were far cry from the taliban
which was executing women in a
soccer stadium given to them by the
united nations and when they were asked
about this these taliban leaders they
said well actually you need to give us
another stadium so we can continue to
execute people in this one and then we
can play games in the other one so you
know let's let's look at the comparative
perspective here yes this was an afghan
government that was challenged but it
wasn't the taliban and it was an afghan
government that tried to help us
uh when i hear people say well you know
the afghan people obviously didn't want
us there uh you know
we see how many afghans
hundreds of thousands of afghans were
willing to sign on to the american
effort to try to build their country in
a better way
who were willing to give their lives to
try to build their country in a better
way and who oh by the way
were willing to help us
to build counterterrorism capabilities
that made us safer
i hope when the history of this is
written that we will remember that this
20 years that we bought
because we were on afghan territory
fighting the counter-terrorism fight
alongside afghans alongside allies from
nato
using intelligence assets that we had
developed to find bin laden and kill him
in pakistan
that that 20 years bought us
a piece that i did not think possible
on september 12th if you had told me we
weren't going to have a big attack like
september 11th again i would have told
you you were out of your mind and so
let's not forget what this 20 years
bought for us and oh by the way
that it did by a chance for the afghan
people uh add something better so
secretary rice in just one second i want
to talk about that because i think that
there's been a sort of willpower failure
in the united states and certainly a
failure of imagination that rivals the
failures of imagination taking place in
the pre-911 era first we have to talk
about policy genius so here's the thing
if you're a responsible adult you need
life insurance right there are people
who rely on you god forbid something
should happen to you you need to make
sure that your stream of income isn't
gone to properly provide for your family
most people need 10 times the life
insurance coverage they get through
their employer policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top insurers all in one place why
compare well you could say 50 or more on
life insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius in fact you could save 300
bucks or more per year on life insurance
by using policy genius to compare
policies the licensed experts at policy
genius work for you not the insurance
companies so you can trust them to help
you navigate every step of the shopping
and buying process that kind of service
has earned policy genius thousands of
five-star reviews across trustpilot and
google and eligible applicants can get
covered in as little as a week thanks to
an award-winning policy option that
swaps the standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call this
exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes advisor higher than
options from ladder ethos and bestow
getting started is super simple first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much life
insurance coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and the scheduling for free
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
head on over to policygenius.com right
now get started policy genius when it
comes to insurance it's nice and really
important to get it right
so let's talk for a second about where
we are now in 2021 you know i was i
believe 17 years old in uh in 2001 it's
been half a generation uh a huge number
of americans not only don't remember 9
11 they weren't alive for 9 11. and so
there seems to be this sort of
counterfactual assumption and no matter
what we did post 9 11 we were bound not
to have another terror attack and
because there was no further severe
terror attack on american soil a
spectacular attack like 9 11. there's an
assumption that no matter what we did it
was never going to happen and we may
very well see the results of that sort
of thinking in exactly the same way that
we saw the results that sort of thinking
on 9 11 given the fact that you have the
president of the united states right now
saying that al qaeda was not in
afghanistan and we had routed them out
they are right back in afghanistan the
haqqani network which was al-qaeda
associated was helping to quote unquote
handle security at at the kabul
international airport and you have isis
which is obviously extraordinarily
active over there are we experiencing a
similar national failure of imagination
like we saw in the late 90s
we certainly are are experiencing some
forgetfulness about what happened on
september 11th and what transpired after
it uh you know i hear a lot about the
mistakes that we made that uh the obama
administration made the trump
administration made
yeah in 20 years uh we made some
mistakes but in an enterprise this tough
this difficult you're going to make some
mistakes
what we did achieve though was a despite
all of mistakes beside missteps
maybe there were other ways to do things
but we achieved what i did not think
possible on september 12th which was not
another attack
it was so frightening after 9 11. we had
we had streams of intelligence talking
about radiological attacks on washington
dc smallpox attacks on the country
constant
threats of another attack it really
wasn't until we captured khalid sheikh
mohammed who was the 911 planner he was
the sort of field general for uh for
north america
that we had a sense of what they might
have been planning and were able to
begin to act on it it wasn't until we
were able to take out some of these
nests to
uh to work with the world actually to uh
trace their their financing in ways that
led us to some of their people and so
what this bought us was an opportunity
to really do the hard work of
counterterrorism i remember ben on at
the president's speech to the congress
the joint session of congress he said
that this fight on terrorism will long
will be
in place long after i'm gone and many of
my successors
and we lost patience because perhaps we
forgot what it was like on september
12th and 13th and 14th when it was
terrifying to go onto an airplane when
it was terrifying to go into the center
of new york city when we worried that
the anthrax attacks were actually
foreign attacks
yes i think we have a bit of amnesia and
i can't blame you know my students here
at stanford who
weren't even conscious on september 11th
but i surely don't understand how those
who were in the congress in the senate
those who were in positions of authority
at that time how they've forgotten that
i can't that i can't forgive so
secretary rice let's talk about some of
the other geostrategic implications of
what just happened in afghanistan
because obviously one major geostrategic
implication is the rise of jihadism
basically everywhere i mean osama bin
laden said in the run-up to 9 11 that he
thought that america was a paper tiger
uh certainly that impression seems to be
uh taking root across the jihadist world
uh the iranians have been getting very
aggressive in their talk about
developing a nuclear weapon uh and and
obviously terror groups have already
seeped back into afghanistan and there
there's a rally this week with with
members of jihadist groups holding a
mock funeral for the united states
complete with with fake coffins um but
there's also some major geostrategic
implications for china and russia
despite the state department's
newfound enthusiasm for large-scale
letter sending to the taliban they said
they've gotten over 100 countries to
sign a letter to the taliban urging them
to allow people to leave china and
russia were not on that list of
countries the u.n security council
resolution that called for freedom of
movement from afghanistan did not
include china did not include russia
both abstained china is already
obviously on the way toward recognizing
the taliban as the legitimate regime in
afghanistan which by the way is a major
shift from 96 to 2001 when only three
countries on planet earth actually
recognize the taliban as a regime saudi
arabia uae and pakistan now you have
major regimes that are going to do so
probably including the united states
given that we have to bribe them to get
people out the russians continue to to
nurture their relationship with the
taliban
and you know as far as other countries
it would be astonishing to me if the
russians don't look with envious eyes of
latvia and estonia and the chinese don't
look at taiwan and say to themselves
what exactly are our limits here
well credibility is not divisible
you can't
lose credibility in one place and
maintain it in other places because
people look at the totality
of what you've become and um now i i
think we should remember that in the the
run-up to 911
al-qaeda got
bolder and bolder first there was the
attack on the world trade center uh in
new york and then there was the attack
on our embassies and in 1998 uh in
tanzania and kenya then there was the
attack on the coal and then there was
the attack of 9 11.
each time we didn't respond they got
bolder and so i expect that the jihadist
movement will be now quite bold uh one
thing that we used to to think and it
was that we had to have an alternative
we had to show people that this wasn't
the only way
now they're going to be able to crow for
some time that they've defeated a major
power and they will attract and they
will recruit on that basis so that's the
first problem the second problem is
actually with our allies i'll come to
china and russia but i'm i'm as
concerned uh that our allies
who apparently weren't really consulted
properly but most importantly had signed
on to this 20-year war
are now wondering about us and it's
going to take some work to rebuild those
relationships and you can't just do it
with words
i'm a i'm a former diplomat i believe in
diplomacy but when it comes to
some of the challenges out there
where we have
bad actors that might try to exploit
it's going to require some action too so
i hope that we're thinking of ways to
send a strong message about taiwan
because the chinese will wonder if we
weren't willing to sustain a presence in
afghanistan given all of the blood and
treasure given the fact that that was
where the attack came from in 9 11 are
we really going to
to help taiwan defend itself as we have
said under the taiwan relations act if
you're in ukraine today
are you really uh believing that if
vladimir putin decides he's going to be
more aggressive in eastern ukraine or
maybe even start to move that line
westward is the united states really
going to respond when it wouldn't stay
in afghanistan given all that
afghanistan meant to us
and for iran
what will it mean to them
about what we're willing to do to defend
our friends and allies from
iranian
groups in iraq or yemen or other places
so
we need some action
i would probably start with taiwan and
that probably means maybe
another robust arms package to taiwan or
some demonstration
that the united states is uh good to its
word because uh our credibility's taken
a hit and
we just have to understand that and and
move on from there yeah secretary ray
say you mentioned our allies and and i
really do wonder if our allies are going
to start to pretty quickly triangulate
and try to make nice with china and
russia given the weakness of the united
states you've seen that sort of thing
from germany with regard to russia
because they're reliant uh in at least
large part on russian oil but i wouldn't
be surprised at all if you see erstwhile
allies in the middle east starting to
make moves toward toward china which is
perfectly happy to do military arms
deals with a lot of our allies in the
middle east simply because
a lot of our allies are feeling like the
united states can't be trusted like in
in some ways it's almost easier to be an
enemy of the united states just wait
them out long enough then it needs to be
an ally who might get undercut
i think that they will ultimately
recognize that the united states is a
better partner than the chinese
are in the middle east but i will say
that for a while they're going to hedge
their bets
look for
some visits from our friends in the
middle east to china look for some
visits for our friends in the middle
east to russia
they're going to want to lay down a a
marker
that
they are prepared to to deal with anyone
because frankly i think a number of them
are are a bit frightened about what we
really are willing to do you know and
and for even our allies in europe i i
don't see uh them uh abandoning nato
i've heard some really kind of uh
apocalyptic scenarios i don't i don't
see that happening but i will i will
tell you this uh they had thought that
maybe some of the things that had
happened uh with europe under the trump
administration were a kind of aberration
uh because you know that they they
thought that it was because president
trump didn't know how to do diplomacy
well they thought in president biden
they had somebody who was an experienced
hand and so maybe this isn't about the
president maybe this is about america
and how america now reads her role in
the world
some
80 plus years
after the end of world war ii and so
that's going to for a while
make them take a step back and wonder
what they whether they can trust us
it's going to take some really hard work
to rebuild it
i don't think it's beyond the realm of
the possible that we can
but
we we aren't going to do that if we just
keep saying no our credibility hasn't
been damaged our credibility's been
damaged final question for you so
obviously we are about to commemorate
the 20th anniversary of 9 11 odd that
was a very odd date for joe biden
originally to pick to pull out of
afghanistan completely you know having
been there at the white house on 9 11
what message would you give to americans
as a reminder of what 9 11 meant and
what it still means
i would say to americans
particularly those of you who were alive
that day
don't ever forget both the fear
that uh we were going to be attacked and
attacked again and attacked again
don't ever forget what it felt like to
try to get on an airplane for the first
time
uh don't ever forget how you felt when
you heard that an airplane went down
that a few weeks later that actually was
not a terrorist attack
and remember that a lot of brave men and
women gave their lives to make sure
that you wouldn't have to fear
they gave their lives to make sure that
your government and your military were
doing what they could to protect you
despite the challenges of being in a
place like afghanistan
and never again take for granted that
america is safe
america's safety is a daily proposition
that has to be worked at constantly
through vigilance and through hard work
and we've made it harder now with the
exit from afghanistan but it's going to
be necessary work that has to has to
continue and i just want to say ben if i
may to the
men and women who who served many of
whom were maimed others families whose
loved ones lost their lives
you you gave us uh 20 years of peace
after the most horrific attack on our
territory since the war of 1812
and that's not going to be forgotten and
it wasn't for nothing um and thank you
for that service
and secretary rice it's an honor and a
pleasure to speak with you uh even
though it has to be during a very dark
time in american history i really
appreciate your time conor lisa rice
thanks so much for joining the ben
shapiro show sunday special
thank you
[Music]
well as we mark the 20th anniversary of
9 11 i think it's important to remember
what we learned from 9 11. in number one
we did learn that america is capable of
coming together in the face of a common
foe i think we all remember if we are
old enough to remember how americans saw
each other as brothers and sisters as
opposed to enemies and opponents it's
something we need to regain i think we
also learned on 911 that the world will
come to our shores that the attempt to
run from the world to hide behind our
borders to hide behind the ocean at that
inevitably failed and that the policies
undertaken by prior administrations
which largely involved ignoring foreign
problems as they fomented
downplaying those problems as they
manifested against american interests
whether we're talking about the american
embassies in kenya and tanzania or the
uss cole how all of that inevitably
leads to worse and worse crises and if
we forget these lessons if we forget
that there are foes out there who want
to destroy the american way of life who
are seeking to destroy our interests and
fight us at every turn if instead we
start to see our enemies not in our
actual enemies but in the people who
live next door to us if we start saying
that the people who share a country with
us are worse enemies than the people who
live overseas who hate our way of life
who wish to see the united states ground
down into the dust then we are a country
that is ripe for our fall and we only
make attacks like 911 more inevitable
the reality is that 911 could have been
prevented the next 911 can be prevented
but only if the united states believes
in itself believes in its own values
believes in the virtue of its citizenry
and only if we are willing to fight on
behalf of those values if not we are
doomed to suffer many more attacks like
9 11 or 20 years our brave men and women
staved those attacks off for 20 years we
remembered the sacrifices of the people
who ran into the burning towers on 911
to save their fellow americans for 20
years those images were ingrained in our
brains now as they fade the lessons that
we learned on 9 11 may be fading along
with them the memories fade over time i
was only 17 when 9 11 happened a lot of
my listeners weren't even born when 911
happened and it's easy to forget what
911 was what it meant and how vulnerable
the united states remained even today in
the face of the fact that 9 11 happened
a very very long time ago but the
reality is that the period between world
war 1 and 2 is about the same as the
period between 9 11 and now
catastrophe can repeat itself
evil act can continue to occur
weaker america is on the world stage the
more america turns inward on itself
rather than orienting outward to spread
its virtues and values on behalf again
of its natural interests the greater the
risk that we repeat some of the
tragedies of the past and so it's
important to remind ourselves of that on
the 20th anniversary of september 11th
the ben shapiro show sunday's special is
produced by mathis glover executive
producer jeremy boring our technical
director is austin stevens and our
assistant director is pavel wydowski our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike caromina hair and makeup is by
fabiola cristina title graphics are by
cynthia angulo the ben shapiro show
sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
[Music]
you